feeling cold is
physically painful
it hurts your
fingers it hurts your feet it hurts your
face
it's also
potentially very life threatening
my focus really is anything cold so if
there is ice or snow
or a cold breeze i want to go there
but i have focused mostly on the polar
regions both in the arctic and antarctic
only 48 people have completed the
unsupported unaided expedition in the
north pole compared to mount everest
where six thousand people have summoned
it's the most difficult expedition on
the planet to a place that few people
understand
a lot of what we see on an expedition to
the arctic ocean is nothing it's like
being on the inside of a ping-pong ball
basically you can't see any sort of
differentiation from the sky to the
horizon to the snow surface
it's also incredible to look out on a
clear day
and see the sheets of ice that are
rafted together like blocks as big as
houses pressured in these amazing
incredible shapes you can't help but
just stop and be amazed
this is my third expedition the north
pole the arctic ocean is changing very
quickly compared to a lot of other
places scientists estimate that the
arctic ocean will be ice free in less
than 50 years in the summertime
unfortunately we find ourselves not
doing these adventures because they're
there anymore but because they might not
be there in the future
our north pole trip realistically may be
the last of its kind in history and so
it was very important for me to do this
adventure so that people have an idea of
what this place is like right now so
that we can look back and say this is
what we once had